day two of the new search for Madeleine
McCann and police were busy clearing a
wooded area on the banks of the Arad
Reservoir this is the place where the
prime suspect and her disappearance is
believed to have frequently visited
later a police dog was taken into that
area that had been cleared while other
officers dug in the dry Earth all hoping
to uncover vital new evidence
Christian b a convicted sex offender
lived in the area when Madeleine went
missing he's denied any involvement but
police are revisiting his old haunts
after a new tip-off
as reported this new information came
from an informant and is viewed as very
credible strong enough to launch the
first search here in almost a decade
Madeline was just three years old when
she went missing she'd been staying here
in the resort of Prior Deluge when she
disappeared
16 years on and the town's name has
become synonymous with the case
Pat and Sheila have been visiting the
area for decades we were here when it
actually happened
very sad the whole thing and we've
talked about it haven't we this time
um but it's for them if they found
something it would be closure I think
that's the best thing and that's the
only way I would look at it
the local church still prays for
Madeleine every week
many here are hoping this search could
finally bring the answers they crave
Siobhan Robbins Sky News in Portugal